this evening at the academy we're going
to show never weaken it was shot in 1921
and the most lovely part about it is a
personal really personally to me is that
it stars both my grandparents and it's
actually at a time when they were dating
and so it's a movie about a boy that
wants to marry a girl and they are
dating and the movies very similar to
exactly what they were doing in real
life Harold had a formula on how he did
his films and you know of course he
started as a silent comedian but he felt
very passionately that his films had to
be in real time with a real person and a
real character and in fact he is
probably the father of romantic comedies
because in his films he was not per se a
character he was a real every man a
person on the street somebody that you
would think of today as a jack lemmon
Tom Hanks maybe a Jim Carrey um he he
wanted to portray a man of the time and
this was a little different as to the
other comedians on the screen so he
could put himself into a situation where
he could have a romance with a girl and
end up connecting and having either a
relationship with her and this was a
theme that he carried through every one
of his movies and that was the boy with
the glasses has the romance and ends up
with the girl at the end of the picture
i think that people who any people that
love movies any type of movies should
really experience what silent movies are
about because the emotion the passion
what you can do with somebody's face
what a gesture of a hand with the turn
of a shoulder can do to affect films
then you know what we do now so much
with rely
on cgi's and putting in extra things
afterwards and not relying per se on the
actor and the actor having to put forth
himself in his personality that
basically shows you a lot about what
acting is
you